Film Courage: In what way can a screenwriter
ruin a scene?
Adam Skelter: It’s almost easier to ask
what way they can fix it because there’s
so many many ways to ruin it.
I mean there’s lots of ways to do something
badly, you know?
Some of the most typical ways are just exposition,
just using the straight I’m going to explain
exactly what I want.
Often if the dialogue is directly proportionate
to the desires like somebody that walks around
and says I want this glass of water.
I want to shake your hand…I want.”
You know when their action is directly proportionate
to what they are saying it tends to get bad,
you’re not revealing anything to the character
and you’re not exposing, you’re not emotionally
engaging.
Although there was a really exception to that.
Did you see THE SACRED DEER?
Film Courage: No I wanted to!
I was watching the trailer and I think I missed
the window at The Laemmle and I wanted to
see it.
Adam: It’s so…I loved it!
He’s an excellent filmmaker and he did this
thing where he is breaking all the rules (there’s
no rules whatever).
But this assumption of having characters say
exactly what they want, exactly what is on
their mind and delivering it in this kind
of deadpan way and it does it in such a way
that is incredibly intriguing and I still
can’t wrap my brain around it.
I’m still trying to understand why it was
so effective but I couldn’t take my eyes
off of it.
It’s Colin Farrell walking around with this
kid [actors Barry Keoghan] talking about the
importance of watches and the importance the
importance of “I think I should get a new
wristband and it’s important.”
And they are very matter of fact and it feels
just left of normal conversation, like it
doesn’t…it feels very contrived, it’s
stilted and it’s for some reason you just
slowly get drawn into this kind of rhythm
and cadence and before you know it you’re
like “Oh, these people, they are not talking
about their watches, they are talking about
what their relationships actually mean to
each other and it’s so well done.
I loved it!
Film Courage: I really want to see that one.
Adam: It’s really darkly funny.
Like there are a few movies this last year
that they felt like these kind of dark dramas
but they were so funny, they were written
in this great absurdist way.
Like MOTHER, I thought MOTHER was hilarious.
Film Courage: I didn’t get to see that.
It looks really intriguing because you couldn’t
really figure out from the trailer what it
was about, it wasn’t clear.
Adam: I’m actually planning a video where
I’m talking about allegory and I think MOTHER
is much more interesting than a lot of people
are giving it credit for just because of…it’s
cool to see a filmmaker who is deliberately
engaging allegory and allegorical tropes in
the way that very few are so it will be fun,
that will be forthcoming, it will be a tease.